Big name
Republicans are
speaking out
against Donald Trump for running
for president in 2024.
Now potential presidential opponents
Mike Pompeo and Mike Pence
they called for more seriousness
and new leadership.
Major Republican
donor and Blackstone CEO
Stephen Schwarzman is
said that he will not back
trump this time.
Senator Mitt Romney
was even more blunt,
telling CNN, quote,
President Trump has lost three i
And if we want to start winning,
we need a new leader.
We assume he means
either the popular vote
or three election cycles.
Trump declared
his latest run from Mar-A-Lago.
Last night,
his speech was filled
with familiar themes
and plenty of falsehoods.
CNN's Daniel Bill is here
with the Fact-Check.
So, Daniel, let's just dove in.
There was so much.
I guess we should start with
what Donald Trump thinks
about climate change and sea lev
The Green New
Deal and the environment,
which they say may affect us
in 300 years,
is all that is talked about.
And yet nuclear weapons,
which would destroy the world
immediately, are never even disc
as a major threat.
Can you imagine?
They say the ocean will rise
one eighth of an inch
over the next 200 to 300 years.
Etc..
It's not true.
It's actually false
in a couple of big ways.
First of all, sea
levels are expected to rise
way more than Trump said here.
He said an eighth of an inch
in 200 years.
The US government's
National Ocean Service
says on its website
that the sea level
along the US
coastline is projected to rise o
about a foot
ten to 12 inches in the next 30
which will be
as much as the rise measured
over the last 100 years.
So Florida,
where Trump gave this speech, Ma
a Lago could see
an increase of multiple feet
this century.
Mar a Lago itself
might well be significantly affe
And second, Trump
generally suggested
that climate change
may only affect us in like 300 y
like in some distant Far-Off thi
That is grossly inaccurate, is i
It is affecting the US today
in a variety of ways,
including more frequent
and more severe storms.
Wildfires, droughts, heatwaves,
It is here. It's not 300 years a
All right.
So he also said this about
that border wall
We are going
to restore
and secure America's borders
just like we had them before. Be
We built a wall
and now we will add to it
now we built the wall.
We completed the wall.
And then we said, let's do more.
And we did a lot more
what he had like that
transparently makes no sense.
I think this is Trump's
attempt to make
it sound like he fully succeeded
on that signature
campaign campaign promise.
In reality,
he only partially fulfilled it.
It's not even close to true
that he completed the wall.
And we have data,
according to an official border
wall status report written by U.
Customs and Border Protection,
two days after he left office,
it was 458
miles of wall completed under Tr
Some of that primary wall,
some of that reinforcement wall,
two existing barriers
but 280 additional miles
that had been identified for wal
construction had not been comple
You can just Google
and find
a bunch of articles
about big gaps in the Wall
after Trump left office.
And like,
obviously it makes no sense
when he says it was finished,
but they were still doing
so-called additions, like, come
Maybe he doesn't know
the country is 3000 miles long
but anyway,
he also tried to compare
thousands of government document
that were found at his Florida h
to other cases involving governm
files being moved at
the rate of Mar a Lago.
Think of it.
And I said,
Why didn't you raid Bush's place
Why didn't you read Clinton
32,000 emails?
Why didn't you raid Clinton's pl
Why didn't you do?
Obama took a lot of things with
We will dismantle
the deep state and restore
government by the people
but what happened there?
This stuff I'm going to call a l
because Trump said it
in August and months ago
and it was debunked
by the National Archives
and Records Administration.
Then he claims in August
that Obama had taken
tens of millions of documents to
And then Nara issued a statement
explaining
this is totally wrong,
that it had itself narrowed
itself, had taken
custody of Obama's record
records after Obama left office,
and never itself
took those records
to a NARA managed facility
in the Chicago area.
And Nara said that
as per federal law,
quote, former President
Obama has no control
over where
and how NARA stole stores
the presidential records
of his administration.
So Trump is trying to make a sou
like Obama did what Trump did
completely wrong.
I feel for Daniel Dell.
I mean, the amount of overtime
that he has to do now
Are you on this side?
People have harder jobs,
but I appreciate it.
Oh, I don't know about that, Dan
And I'm going to send you some v
some mega vitamin D, incredible
Okay. That's what he needs than
Thank you very much.
Are joining us now.
Sara Matthews served
as White House
deputy press secretary
in the Trump administration.
Former Illinois
Congressman Joe Walsh ran
against Trump for the Republican
presidential nomination in 20, 2
Welcome to you both.
Congressman, let me start with y
This speech last night
was at Mar a Lago in front of hi
I guess they were cheering,
but not the crowds
we typically see Trump in front
What do you think of the content
and the setting that was
chosen for this announcement?
Victor, I don't
yes, it was a very boring speech
It was low energy.
It was filled with thousands of
because that's what Donald Trump
But I don't think
this speech at all matters.
Look, here's the deal is we talk
that guy Donald Trump
is the clear favorite
to be the Republican Party
nominee in 20, 24.
The speech doesn't matter.
And respectfully,
it doesn't matter what Mitch
McConnell or Kevin
McCarthy or Rupert Murdoch
or Tucker
Carlson or Sean Hannity
or all
the Republican donors in the wor
the only thing that matters
is where Republican voters are.
And generally,
they're still strongly with him.
And that's such an interesting
perspective, Congressman.
We'll get back to more of that
in a minute.
But, Sarah,
because you know
President Trump
and work with President Trump,
I do want to get your impression
of his speech last night.
What do you think?
I mean, it definitely
was a boring speech.
We've heard that from a lot of f
It was uninspiring.
I worked for him.
I've seen him give plenty of spe
during that time.
And it was by far
one of his most low energy.
I mean, he himself seemed bored
And I think it's 20, 16
Trump saw 20, 22 Trump give that
He would have called it low ener
I think for a presidential annou
You want your speech to be
something that is,
you know,
uplifting inspiring hope
and Forward-Looking
and this just kind of
turned into a rambling, incohere
mess, etc.
one very quickly, what's that ab
I mean what we've heard
from Maggie Haberman,
her reporting is that his heart'
What's that about?
It does seem like he might be ru
because he thinks that it's
going to shield him
from these criminal investigatio
that are swarming around him.
I don't think
that's going to make a differenc
But I do think that in his eyes,
he thinks
he can message that to his suppo
and to the American people as,
hey, they're coming after me
because I'm running for presiden
and they don't want to see me
get elected again.
And so that seems to be
part of his strategy.
Hmm.
Congressman, to your point,
the former president
dominating the field
for 20, 24 nomination for Republ
Let's put up the poll.
This is from New York Times.
He had a college 49% support
former President Trump
governor Ron DeSantis at 26.
No one else in double digits in
just to support what you just sa
But also
I want you to listen
to what Senator Josh Hawley says
and this is the carryover
from the speech from the former
to what we saw today with the vo
for Mitch McConnell
to lead Republicans in the Senat
I think Senator McConnell's view
is, is that Trump is largely to
that Republicans have an image p
Trump, I have to say that
I don't agree with that.
What do you make of what you're
generally there that the theory
from Josh Hawley
and what is Josh Hawley doing?
He said the Republican Party is
That is not the Trump image prob
What do you see and hear in that
that sound bite?
Well,
I think, Victor,
that Hawley and Cruz said a lot
this is well, they want this
Republican Party,
my former political party,
to to even be stronger down this
kind of a national ballistic
build a wall around America.
Go after CNN and go after the li
make America a Christian theocra
The movement concerned
that it's now in the party like
They want the Republican Party
to push this stuff a lot more.
But again, that
just that just helps Trump
because that's the kind of crap
that Donald Trump espouses.
Congressman, one more
follow up about Carrie Lake.
She lost her race in Arizona.
The Wall Street Journal
editorial board says if Carrie
Lake couldn't win on
Stop the Steal
in 20, 22,
it's hard to see how anyone else
pull it off.
Maybe at last the 2020 election
You see something different
and you predict something differ
for her future.
Oh, yeah.
Look to me.
Carrie Lake's a star.
And Alison, I won't bet anybody
but I wouldn't at all
be surprised if Trump in three m
announces Carrie Lake
as his vice presidential pick.
Super, super early.
He loves her.
She she epitomizes his message.
His election the nine attack dem
She's still saying
the 2020 election was stolen.
And she's very good and very smo
and very polished.
As to how she leads
with this election denialism stu
Look, I don't write Trump's
obituary yet, Alisyn.
And I don't think
I don't think we should write.
Election denialism is still a hu
of this Republican Party.
Quickly before we go, Sara,
do you think
former President Trump can handl
that much star power at number t
on the ticket with him?
I do think that he would be
worried about Kerry showing up.
I mean, given her background
as a former journalist,
you know, she's very good on TV,
but I also don't know if I see h
picking her
as a potential running mate
because had she won her race,
maybe it would have been differe
But she's a loser.
And so I don't see him
wanting to join forces
with someone like that.